manifestantes frente a la embajada
francesa en wagadugo el domingo para
mostrar su rechazo a la antigua potencia
colonial de burkina faso acusada de
ayudar al Coronel damiba ahora derrocado
a volver al poder trascer sustituido en
un golpe de estado por el nuevo líder
autoproclamado El capitán Ibrahim traore
[Aplausos]
Dame
destruido burkina faso pero gracias a
Dios Tenemos un gran hombre fuerte como
ibrahimtraoré para salvarnos a todos
a pesar de las celebraciones el ambiente
de la manifestación empeoró cuando
prendieron fuego a las barreras frente a
la embajada algo a lo que la seguridad
del recinto respondió con gases en
lacrimógenos tanto Francia como damiba
han negado las acusaciones de estar
tramando una contraofensiva tras negarse
inicialmente los líderes sociales y las
personalidades religiosas afirman que
damiba aceptó dimitir el domingo
a las nuevas autoridades de burkina faso
les invito a trabajar para unirse en
lugar de dispersarse líderes
comunitarios y religiosos dicen que la
dimisión ha sido aceptada por traore que
justifica su golpe con el fracaso de
damiba en el control de la creciente
insurgente es la amista en el país A
pesar de ello el nuevo líder
autoproclamado dice que respaldará la
junta de dámeva
hemos decidido por unanimidad apoyarán
mpsr en el cumplimiento de su misión
relativa a y la seguridad de la
población
dispuestos a ayudar en la lucha contra
el terrorismo
rismo palabras que han desatado
especulaciones sobre si burkina faso
podría recurrir a Rusia el lunes el
kremlin pidió que se restablezca el
orden tras el golpe